foreign
[Music]
hello good afternoon everyone thank you
for joining us
I don't know what what's better but
right before lunch or right after lunch
I don't know so hopefully everyone's uh
feeling pretty good so I want to welcome
you all to the Intel session here at
Google Cloud next and we're gonna have a
quick little time to talk through some
fun and interesting stuff we're doing
with our great partner Google and with
some of our customers and then we're
going to try to leave some time at the
end for questions so if you have any
questions
um there's a mic right here and we'll be
available and hopefully have a chance to
get through some of those uh by way of
introduction uh my name is Lisa Spellman
and I am a corporate vice president and
general manager of the Xeon products and
solutions at Intel next Tuesday is my 23
years there so I can't even believe it
but I've been at Intel long time done a
lot of different roles there and spent
the last several working on our Xeon
products with our wonderful customers
like Google I'm joined by two colleagues
here I have Katie from the Google Cloud
team and I have Sue Chang from Palo Alto
works and I look forward to having the
chance to introduce you to them and get
you the opportunity to hear a little bit
about their story so first we're going
to sit here and just talk a little bit
about the history of the partnership so
Intel and Google have worked together
for ever I mean you know since the
beginning of the company in the
beginning of cloud computing but we've
really solidified and strengthened our
partnership since 2016 in building out
the gcp portfolio and product line and
just creating all these you know
Wonderful Enterprise Services high
performance Computing Telco Edge AI you
know just the whole gamut of workloads
working together it's been a great
partnership that is built on a
foundation not only of solving customer
needs and customer requirements but on
pushing the Forefront and the edges of
innovation and we're going to share a
little bit about that today I also want
to take a moment to thank and
congratulate our partners at Google
Cloud for being the very first
hyperscaler to have our fourth gen Intel
Xeon Processor available for customers
they were early adopters and had just
deep engineering engagement to get
private preview out ahead of the game
and then they followed that up with
General availability of several really
great instances that Katie will talk a
little bit more about so it's a great
partnership and we're very grateful for
the work in the joint engineering we
have the opportunity to do together
okay
so I'm going to talk for a minute about
the 4th gen Xeon product so the Xeon
product is you know the foundation of
essentially all data center you know
Cloud to Edge workloads out there the
beauty of it it is the truest form of
general purpose and it can run any
workload out of the box over the years
we've continued to invest in adding
acceleration for more and different
workloads to move from Pure general
purpose into general purpose plus so
general purpose with acceleration that's
built in and in this generation we
really increase the levels of
acceleration that we added
um we have just an average across the
variety of workloads on the product we
delivered a 50 little over 50 percent
workload uh performance Improvement and
so that's just you know again a single
generation and the opportunity to
increase the performance of your
workloads by 50 in very much the same
kind of cost structure so that's just
total cost of ownership value to the
bottom line and delivering what ends up
to be a 3X better total cost of
ownership output so that TCO is one of
the most important metrics that we work
together with our partners and with the
industry on making sure that we're
accelerating the right workloads and
that we're bringing down the entire cost
of the solution not just the performance
delivered only through the CPU so we're
really focused on that you know
efficiency and efficiency of innovation
as we all are aware and you're seeing
all over the con the conference
artificial intelligence is uh one of the
fastest growing workloads and if you
look at the size of the artificial
intelligence workload by compute cycles
that it consumes you know you sit there
and you have all workloads and then
artificial intelligence and the kegger
or the growth of AI is just phenomenal
so many opportunities are being opened
up new Services being deployed and
developed that's why we've invested in
actually adding acceleration into the
processor that is specifically dedicated
to accelerating AI workloads so classic
machine learning deep learning focused
on generative AI so both increasing the
processing speed as well as the memory
and memory bandwidth speeds and
capabilities so that you can get even
more out of your infrastructure we're
also focusing on delivering the right
software foundation so we've dedicated
years of effort to ensuring that the
most you know performant and popular
Frameworks and AI software algorithmic
models are running well out of the box
on Xeon and this is an area where we're
going to continue to invest many AI
workloads are delivered on gpus and they
have excellent performance but your CPU
infrastructure is often not fully
utilized and with this type of AI
acceleration built in you can further
drop down the TCO of your AI workloads
because you're using under utilized
capacity and taking advantage of compute
cycles that you already own and that
you're already paying for so we think
it's a really great win-win and a way to
kind of complement your infrastructure
deployment decisions so we are spending
a lot of effort in this space we're
investing in state-of-the-art generative
AI capabilities to ensure that you know
all of our customers have the
opportunity to take advantage of both
the hardware and the software
acceleration that's built in and it's
just an area where we see so much
potential across all Industries like
this is absolutely not specific to One
Singular you know vertical or industry
type we see it really changing the way
that so many services are delivering
okay
um I talked a little bit about the
partnership that we have and I I talked
about some of the history of Intel and
Google working together this is just
some of the you know examples of what
you see from Intel and Google where we
partner together and again this is
delivering across you know
infrastructure modernization and really
trying to put in place the services and
the capabilities that allow you to take
your existing infrastructure and again
whether that's a lift and shift or a
complete application modernization and
moving to more of a cloud native type of
offering we want to offer and support
that full gamut that full range of
capabilities Google is you know well
known in the cloud industry for their
depth and expertise and the AI and
machine learning space and that's
another area where you know we continue
to invest together to provide that right
landing and and launch pad for you know
all of Industry these workloads we focus
together on delivering that consistent
and balanced performance so that you
have the opportunity to ensure the right
slas and can smooth any of those
transitions of workloads that maybe have
previously run in an on-prem environment
and are now moving to a more you know
Cloud scale and Cloud structure we also
have focused on ensuring that we're
delivering across you know all regions
of the world to support the truly Global
nature of so many uh so much of business
that's done today
our general purpose compute instances
are designed to again deliver that
consistent performance that can handle
you know every workload and is the
backbone of your infrastructure we also
have worked together on the higher
performance Computing instances which
Katie will talk about as well as higher
memory instances as well that offer the
chance to move to your in-memory
databases in the cloud and again achieve
that excellent TCO well you can
accelerate the pace of taking advantage
of new generations of technology so it's
been you know a great partnership I
think part of the value that Intel and
Google bring together is also the
partnership work we do with you know
major other players in the industry you
see you know sap Oracle VMware mentioned
there very you know tight relationships
to ensure that again everything we're
delivering is at that Enterprise class
for you
okay
um
I want to now have a minute and just
invite up Katie so Katie as someone I've
known in the industry for years and
years he is leading a very important
part of the Google Cloud portfolio and
the business and he's driving all of
their compute Services their AI their
machine learning and he's going to take
a minute to talk to you a little bit
more about the specific innovations that
Google cloud has brought to Market in
their brand new C3 and H3 instances so
Katie why don't you come up
thank you thank you Lisa
Intel and Google have had a long history
of deeply working together and Lisa
mentioned that in her opening
when Google Cloud started out
we start with the N1 instance
and we built it on Intel we started with
the first generation Xeon on N1
and over the years we've expanded our
portfolio
they've expanded across multiple
families of Xeon processors
to where we are today
a full portfolio
finely tuned
to workload needs which can be slightly
different
whether you're looking for something
that's memory intensive
more general purpose
more performant
a cost efficient part of the portfolio
or you may be looking for just the
absolute best inconsistency which is
what we've done with C3
I'll talk a little bit more about C3 and
H3 which are the latest members of our
family
and uh
the latest to come with Intel's fourth
generation Xeon and I'll talk a little
bit more about that in a few seconds
but I also want to mention that
a lot of the workloads that you all run
are VMware workloads
and one of the things that we've done
also is just announced over the last few
days are ve2
uh VMware engine instance to get those
workloads onto benefit the benefits of
cloud the elasticity and the Automation
in the cloud
okay
C3
C3 is an amazing VM
why is it an amazing VM
we deeply partnered with Intel on the
fourth generation Xeon to bring that to
Market first
but that was the start
we have 35 Better Price performance
we lit up the AMX instruction set which
is 12 times the performance uh in that
in that realm of AI workloads
we lit up confidential computing
with the TDX so that
four workloads four users that require
that level of security you have that
option now
but that was the start because workloads
need compute
workloads need other things they need
networking they need storage they need
other services and so we partnered again
with Intel on the ipu
200 gigabits per second three times the
packet processing versus a prior
generation that's that's the power of
the network that we're bringing to this
machine
what our customers are doing with it is
even more they're saying now that you've
got this offload engine
can I offload my encryption so that I
have even more consistency and even more
performance for my workloads that are
residing on the main processor
so second pillar on the networking side
again a joint Innovation with Lisa with
her team with Intel
uh lighting up the magic within within
C3
and finally storage
hyperdisc is truly unique
um we heard about titanium from Thomas
on day one
the ipu and hyperdesk are part of that
titanium architecture a new way to drive
even more efficiency even more offloads
through a scale out architecture what
hyperdisc does is it gives you
tremendous storage block storage
performance it gives you tremendous iops
350 000 iops 10x
better performance in the product
Generation
Um
at the end of the day what matters are
the workloads and how it does on them so
we profile this on a number of workloads
and you've seen those on the chart there
this is a fantastic machine for
Enterprise grade performance for deep
consistency and something we are truly
like proud of
in working with Intel Department
H3 H3 takes everything that C3 got to
the market
so all of that Innovation and compute
all of that Innovation and networking
and Storage
is here
however there is a market need within
HPC that is truly unique
and to address that we said what else
can we do how much more can we do and we
partnered with Intel on deos and the
parallel store file system to give a
luster-like file system for those high
performance computing workloads so H3
again announced just recently you can
see the numbers on the on the uh
different workloads and Frameworks out
there it's truly a new member of our
family built on the Innovation we've
driven together uh with Intel and taking
that Innovation to new areas uh into the
software Ram into the file system realm
to bring that whole package for the
workloads
at the end of the day
it's a deep partnership based on
technology between two Innovative
companies but the key goal is to light
up that magic and bring that Innovation
for you all so I'm super happy about
this and that I'll get Lisa back on
stage
all right thank you
um so I I'd be remiss too if I I didn't
mention
um just the incredible work that has
been done to continuously improve the
sustainability of these offerings too we
are so well aware of how important that
has become in the decisions of what
infrastructure you're going to support
what you're going to use and land and
it's it's a really strong partnership
there
um the Intel Xeon Processor is
manufactured almost completely on
renewable energy so 90 to 95 so it's the
most sustainably manufactured processor
on the planet and then you pair it with
the you know infrastructure leadership
that the Google engineering team
delivers and you you really do get
strong improvements every generation in
that performance and performance per
watt so you have the opportunity to not
only you know capture some of that value
you heard Katie talk about some of that
but you also can utilize that to meet
your ESG goals and continue to advance
your company's sustainability uh
progress and goals so Katie was kind
enough to let me show this next slide
which has a bunch of the performance
that is delivered through the instances
that his team has created and built for
the market so these are real generation
over generation you know from the end to
to the C3 Real Results tested built and
shown and because of that early private
preview work you saw a couple of the
quotes but what we have is we have you
know real customers that are already
experiencing these benefits and so if I
could encourage you to do any anything
out of this it would be really to go
take some time and start playing around
with this and and really kind of see
what C3 and H3 can do how you can start
to advance your confidential Computing
for you know your workloads and your
data that it demands it because there's
a lot of really good value there that
should be enough to help you know Propel
you forward so we're really excited
about delivering this type of
performance on workloads we've talked
about you know integrated accelerators
for AI you can see that show up in the
numbers but you also see that show up in
other areas as well where that
performance Jennifer den and that value
just continues to go up
um also if there's a workload that you
can't find in any of our collateral and
messaging we've tested a lot of them but
we're always happy to help and help you
you know make that value proposition uh
pitch and make it really work for you so
we're proud of all of that work okay so
the um next uh portion here is actually
one of our shared customers so both
Intel and Google have a multi-year
relationship with Palo Alto networks a
industry leader and they've been doing
some very Innovative work in the space
of network threat detection and they
were one of our earliest users of the C3
instances and I'd like to invite up to
the stage Su Chang who's a senior
distinguished engineer at Palo Alto
networks and has played just an
instrumental role in delivering the Palo
Alto Network Services out to their
customers and maybe many of you are
actually Palo Alto networks customers so
he's going to come up here and just talk
a little bit about the journey to
deliver you know AI based Network threat
detection services and how that's been
going for them so why don't you come on
up on stage
okay all right thank you okay thank you
thank you Rita for inviting me to the
talk
I'm happy to share what we are doing in
part of the networks and uh how Google
and Intel is helping us to do this
um in part of the networks we detect uh
Network a Detachment work that was that
the network threats can come from the
inside from a compromise user talk to
the command control in the internet or
it can be a Outsider attacker to inject
command injection into your network so
in part of the levels we uh we have this
involvement of threat detection
mechanisms at the beginning we collect
the virus samples from the wild and we
analyze it we
write up signatures to match it and uh
and we deploy these signatures in all
the firewalls and when the virus come
along in the network we method we block
it so that's what's great but as covet
virus is a network virus evolves too
they mutate they have variants and it's
just that they do a whole lot faster so
the humanly involved signature
development is not enough so that's
where Network machine learning comes
along machine learning can detect
unknown never seen before stress more
capability and then over the years the
threats keep evolving and we keep
evolving the
we who employ more sophisticated
Machinery like deep learning with neural
network
um your network as you know is a very
expensive business it's uh millions of
ways and then they have to take a lot of
CPU and memory to deploy it so it's hard
to deploy it in the firewall as a
cost-effective way so in part of the
networks we developed a architecture to
pick some suspicious traffic sent to the
cloud and we use the cloud service to
help the firewall to detect threat uses
so we deployed our model in the cloud
and then now
with Intel and Google's help we can
deploy it in a efficient way because we
need to do this in a super fast to
because of the nature of the inline
traffic we cannot take too long so it's
a in-line traffic we need a human
latency a super fast latency uh maybe
the next slide please
okay so in this journey we we take a
help from Intel and Google so from Intel
with the latest generation of Dion
processor there are capabilities
specifically designed for machine
learning and deep learning so we get
this help from Intel to look at their
technology in the
I I said two years ago when we developed
this new service uh Intel already have
is a second generation and third
generation VR in the cloud and now
it also have the
libraries and tools to help us to
optimize the models from s floating
points 32-bit to into eight to quantize
the model and uh with that also the VM
processor has a vni in such a set
specific build for machine learning
workload so with this combined we were
able to achieve 6X performance scaling
where we delivered the service to the
cloud and then later this year Intel
come up with the new processor sephor
Rapids and with the new instruction set
AMX and we realized that oh that doubles
are performing performance again so all
together it's a 12x faster comparing to
the previous
earlier implementation and with Google's
help these Technologies are deployed in
the gcp pretty fast and we were able to
migrate our service to its uh relatively
easy uh no Cool Change needed um enter
the library or the building in the
machine learning framework in tensorflow
so we pick it up very easily and as a
matter of fact we actually migrate the
the migrated new workload is turned on
live on Monday two days ago so uh great
work uh yeah that's what I want to share
thank you
[Applause]
okay so some of you might not know but
the engineers first presentation in
front of you know big audience like this
and so a special Round of Applause for
nailing it
and also I just want to share we were
talking this morning and and you know
the graph shows that performance
Improvement but it is feedback from our
customers that motivates us and drives
our changes in Behavior so
um when we first offered uh out started
putting acceleration for AI into our
processors we had some of our own
um versions of Frameworks and we got the
strong feedback from customers like Palo
Alto Network said hey you really got to
get upstreamed you got to get into
tensorflow and that's how we're going to
make these Services actually you know go
to market and be usable and we take that
feedback very seriously and have spent
you know the time and put in the
software engineering work to ensure that
we are Upstream so that it's not hard to
use these capabilities that you you know
you get your instance you log in you use
you know standard versions of the
Frameworks you know the main branch and
then you're getting all of that benefit
and value so we really do appreciate and
value feedback like that to make all of
our technology easy year to adopt and
use and get benefits from
which gears a little bit to talk about
um a software a SAS company that Intel
actually acquired called granulate and I
want to introduce you to them in case
you haven't had a chance to meet them so
granulite's a very cool technology that
is built just to make you guys look good
that's it so what it does is the team
you know lands an agent onto your uh
into your infrastructure it has no code
changes it's not touching your data it
has no access to that but it is watching
for traffic patterns and looking at the
way that you are utilizing your
instances utilizing your VMS where your
pressure points are where your
bottlenecking where your CPUs are
getting bottled after the IP or other
parts of the network storage whatever it
is then after it has some time analyzing
it starts to make recommendations and
puts a performance agent that's there
that helps reroute traffic and through
that delivers to you cost savings as
well as performance increases and one of
the cool things about their model is
that you're not paying for any of that
until they have proven to you that your
costs are coming down so we recently had
the opportunity to you know go through
the Google process and get this put on
the Google marketplace so it's now
available for everyone to use uh has
that opportunity and I just I think
Solutions like that that are you know
Roi guaranteed
um are are so great I was actually
chatting with the granulate team and I
said well does anybody ever turn it off
and they said well we haven't had any
customers yet that said you know what
I'd like to stop saving money so I I
guess once you're once you're in you're
you're pretty in if any of you have any
questions afterwards we do have a booth
in our demo and then my friend here in
the bright orange he addressed so that
you could find him is our resident
granulate expert and would be happy to
you know take questions and and ask
about that but we're seeing like really
strong benefits and this ability to
continue to optimize even within like a
very well optimized infrastructure and
optimize workloads there is always room
to be more efficient and this is a way
that you know you can help demonstrate
how you're bringing costs of your
service down as well so I have an
example here that I'll show this is one
of the granulate's customers here
um you know running in Cloud
infrastructure and nilas has 50 000
developers in their environment that are
using so you know it's got some high
intensity to it it has lots of you know
busy traffic times and and can have a
lot of you know congestion but as
they've been delivering support for
their 50 000 developers worldwide
they've simultaneously been able to
achieve these uh results so 58 reduction
in response time that's huge to your
developer Community nobody wants their
developers waiting and developers have
such a low tolerance for waiting anyways
so it's really you know a win-win but
they're also bringing down the cost of
their services and you might think why
would Intel and Google Cloud want to
bring down the cost like that's their
revenue but the reality is that we know
over years the more efficient and better
performing your infrastructure is the
more new services and new capabilities
that your business can afford to launch
and deliver Revenue yourselves so we see
this you know self-fulfilling flywheel
of the greater the efficiency the
greater the performance the greater the
opportunities are that open up so
anyways I encourage you to take a look
in the marketplace see if granulate
might be a good offering for you and
something to explore we're pretty
excited about the potential that it has
to offer okay so we're just about to the
time for some q a
um I uh I think I my uh I need can you
click to the next slide for some reason
this guy stopped clicking
um
I just wanted to you know close out here
with a couple of action items
um
can you guys click to the next slide and
stop to
there we go okay so the action items I
already talked about one of them please
go out play around a little bit test out
C3 test out H3 look at TDX like start to
think about your confidential Computing
environment and and what you need there
um our fourth gen uh fourth gen power
gcp instances oh it's okay I'm on my
last one this is it okay uh powered
instances are available today so
um take a opportunity to look into them
test your workloads and then the last
one is you know swing by the booth so we
have
um we have generative AI demos up and
running on C3 we have a really cool high
performance Computing uh on H3 we've got
a granulate demo to show you exactly
what I talked about happening and and
the opportunity to see how the agent
works and answer any of the questions
you might have around you know like the
security of it or
um you know just how does it interact
within my system and my application so I
encourage you to you know take all of
those steps in your busy rest of your
day and afternoon
foreign